a lot of luck about it this is the  genera of someone who passed away due to  the corona virus  allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala accept him as  a Shaheed as you see because of the dead  virus we cannot even perform muslimah  yet with water we cannot perform the  whistle with water which is why we have  to do that IMO which constitutes as a  whistle with soil and you know  subhanAllah looking at this it's an  honor for this brother because the  Shahada that died on the battlefield  they we are not to perform whistle upon  them on them and they are very just like  that and this brother died because of  the plague and Allahu Akbar  we could not even perform the listen  with water and we had to do that IMO so  this is an honor for him we ask Allah  Subhanahu WA Ta'ala to express heed